il la parole est un monsieur claude
goasguen si monsieur le président la
question se pose aujourd'hui sur les
institutions européennes et je voudrais
adresser ma question ministère à faire
au ministre des affaires étrangères
à quoi sert l'europe à quoi sert
l'europe alors que à la frontière de
l'europe le massacre airplay sacré le
génocide religieux des minorités yazidi
des minorités chrétiennes sous les yeux
de l'europe nous laisse dans une
indifférence totale
pas seulement en france mais que
visiblement la commission européenne a
d'autres choses à faire sans doute très
importante mais néanmoins ce que nous
avons voulu une europe qui soit à ce
point spectatrice qu'elle laisse à ses
frontières tuer et massacrer des
chrétiens les chrétiens d'orient
voilà la question alors la question que
je pose au ministre des affaires
étrangères j'entends bien que la france
est engagée plus que d'autres nations
dans ce grand cataclysme qui frappe le
moyen-orient mais je voudrais que la
france rappelle à la commission
européenne que ses objectifs ne sont pas
simplement de mettre en place des
technostructures et de gérer des
affaires économiques mais aussi de faire
respecter l'identité européenne lorsque
les droits de l'homme sont à ce point et
qu'on incite à un génocide religieux la
deuxième question porte sur la turquie
car la turquie qui réclament à cor et à
cri et qu'il réclamait en tout cas son
entrée dans l'europe peut-elle désormais
continuer à avoir cette attitude qui
consiste à laisser ses frontières
ouvertes par où passent les armes par on
passe le pétrole qui achètent le pétrole
d'ailleurs c'est une vraie question est
ce que de temps en temps la commission
européenne pourrait rappeler à la
turquie qu'on ne peut pas vouloir à la
fois être européen et combattre l'idéal
européen par ailleurs merci la parole
est à monsieur harlem désir secrétaire
d'état chargé des affaires européennes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député claude goasguen
vous l'avez dit les minutes les
minorités y est idéal
chrétiens d'orient sont aujourd'hui
victimes d'une barbarie celles des
groupes jihad aux terroristes de dash au
moyen-orient face à la gravité de la
situation la france a pris l'initiative
le ministre affaires étrangères a
présidé fin mars une réunion du conseil
de sécurité consacrée à cette question
c'était une première la france a adressé
un message clair la communauté
internationale doit se mobiliser pour
permettre le retour des chrétiens et des
autres minorités persécutées sur les
terres qui sont les leurs nous avons
proposé
vous menez un peu d'action soit élaborée
avec quatre volets un volet humanitaire
nous proposons la création d'un fonds
dès le retour un volet militaire
la stratégie de la coalition
internationale et des forces locales
doit intégrer l'exigence du retour des
minorités et la sécurisation de ce
retour et la france est engagée ainsi
que de nombreux pays européens même
s'ils ne le sont pas tous
et s'il est vrai que nous souhaiterions
que davantage de partenaires
s'impliquent aujourd'hui dans ces
opérations
un volet judiciaire les auteurs de
crimes de guerre et de crimes contre
l'humanité doivent être jugées par la
cour pénale internationale et enfin un
volet politique parce qu'il n'y aura pas
de ré enracinement durable des minorités
sans état inclusif c'est-à-dire
garantissant les droits de tous les
citoyens
c'est le sens de l'action du ministre
des affaires étrangères pour qu'il y ait
en irak mais aussi en syrie une solution
politique qui soit trouvé avec des
gouvernement inclusif
les nations unies sont également
pleinement mobilisés le secrétaire
général des nations unies c'était notre
demande est en train de constituer un
groupe d'experts pour travailler sur ces
questions est par ailleurs en septembre
la france accueillera une conférence
internationale au cours de laquelle nous
ferons le point sur cette charte
d'action pour la protection des
personnes victimes de violences
ethniques ou religieuses soyons clairs
la solution pour sauver la syrie la
région les minorités qui la composent
elle est politique et c'est ce qui guide
l'action de la mer aux imf féminine mois